going back to the beginning of the film
did you already have the family members
of these rapists lined up did you know
how to contact them because I mean you
went into some very looks like rural
areas and that's right how'd it all
basically i started off brainstorming
what i wanted the film to feel like to
look like you know really analyzing what
were my objectives in making this film
i've ended a period of quite intensive
research in terms of just finding all
the footage i could of the reports and
this was a very very well covered well
reported incident and i started writing
a list of questions for the rapists and
worked with a psychiatrist had a
forensic criminologist helped me with
some of those questions and and started
weeding around the whole you know the
whole subject very diligently and then
at a certain point i managed to get hold
of trial transcripts and of course i
also had appointed a researcher who
found some of the addresses through the
legal system because all of the court d
positions have the name and the address
so we had names and addresses but we
hadn't aligned anyone up basically it
was a question of doorstepping in pretty
much every case other than with the
prison because that was set up in
advance and i think it's very hard for
me to say because i was never faced with
this but i think if i had been told I
couldn't interview those rapists I might
just not have finished this film or
maybe not even have started it to me
that was absolutely imperative there
were three things I wanted to deliver
with this film the first was that the
protests should be amplified that they
would be the heartbeat and the pulse
of this film because they are ultimately
what made me feel very optimistic that
the time had come to deal
comprehensively with this issue that the
world has neglected and abandoned for
many years the second thing was that it
was very disturbing to me that this
young girl whose entire life was before
her was just referred to as this 23 year
old medical student in the press that
was it you know who had gone to see a
movie with a friend that's all we knew
about her and in fact until the film
came out nothing more was known about
her so it seemed to me to be crucial to
delve into and and find out and document
what we have lost in this girl's murder
and the third and absolutely vital leg
of of my objectives was to understand
why men do this and to you know if you
if you can't understand them how are you
going to change them so I needed to know
what goes on in the head of a man who
who does this to a woman who not only
gang rapes her but eviscerates her who
pulls out her intestines and you know
what his attitudes to women are where
they come from who the significant
female figures in his life had been what
he feels about them what is his notion
of manhood what is a man what's a good
girl what's a bad girl you know so there
were 150 questions I had
you